[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: In this
video, we will show you
how to predict prices using
a machine learning model
from Google Sheets, find
NASDAQ composite index
price historical data and
download it, open the sheet,
import the data,
and create a chart.
Open Script Editor.
Go to ml-integration-samples
at GitHub and copy the code.
Go back to Script Editor.
Paste the code.
Add BigQuery API service.
Deploy the code.
In the sheet, specify
GCP project ID.
Select Date and Open columns.
Train the model.
Add 900 rows and select them
to forecast the price movement
for the next 900 days.
Select Forecast to render
the price prediction.
That's it.
To learn more about the ML
integration sample code,
look at the links in
the video description.